well I don't do politics on this show
but you can't help but notice the events
in the last 24 hours
Ted Cruz steps aside in the presidential
race John Kasich Governor Kasich is
going to step aside this afternoon in
the presidential race leaving Donald
Trump Hillary Clinton to which all of
America looks at Hillary Clinton and
says yay
or you've got to be kidding the rest of
America looks at Donald Trump and says
yay or you've got to be kidding and yet
the rest of America goes oh my god these
are our choices to We the People oh no
oh no personal disrespect either one I
mean I know some of you love Donald
Trump and some of you love Hillary
Clinton but most people are just going
say what really oh I'm not putting
myself in any one of those camps except
I'll tell you I'll be in the never
Hillary camp but that was fairly
predictable but I could friends er I've
got a good friend is actually a very
good friend of hers and he just swears
she's could be an awesome president
that's it that's where I'll just where
if she's president but but anyway oh my
gosh we do all spend an awful lot of
energy on this in this country don't we
certainly a lot of money I mean if
you're watching news channels you would
think there's nothing else going on in
the entire world ever in the history of
the world but um and then there's the
rest of us are bound to succeed
regardless of who's in the White House
because what happens in your house is
more important than what happens in the
White House but it is just kind of weird
times I don't know it's weird there's a
whole lot of people going
really this what has happened Oh ice one
guy he said yeah things are bad in
Gotham we got the Catwoman or we got
Joker ah yeah let's oh my gosh hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind